a small California community oneself
tackle a looming global pilot shortage
as airlines try to recruit an estimated
800,000 new aviators over the next 20
years
so our Meg Oliver yes she's ours went up
in the plane to see how Ridley
California sees a big opportunity to
train the next generation of pilots the
city will announce a new partnership
with Boeing later today meg has just got
back from weed Lee so Meg welcome thank
you jack what are they doing all right
good morning to all to you local
officials hope it's a job revolution
turning this large agricultural region
into a pilot training hub it all started
when this down on its luck town bought a
few airplanes that attracted the world's
largest aerospace company and now it
looks like the sky's the limit in the
library at Jefferson Elementary the home
of the Jets passengers down 11 year-old
Anthony Corona sits at the controls of a
flight simulator usually reserved for
professional pilots so you're pretty
good yep would you consider yourself an
expert no I just got myself a pro how it
got here is a story that started with
the town in the verge of bankruptcy
really California's nestled in the
state's vast Central Valley during World
War two it was a busy training ground
for pilots but today 76 percent of its
residents are low-income how bad did the
unemployment rate get so in really the
unemployment rate got up to 33 percent
Town Manager Nicole ziba says her
community's economy rose and fell with
the agriculture industry you knew you
needed to make a radical decision so I
say desperation breeds innovation a few
years ago she applied for in one a
technology grant she used it to buy for
electric planes there are 70 in the
world and you have four of them here in
Reedley we have four which means that we
have the largest concentration of
production all-electric aircraft not
only in the nation but in the world she
planned to use them to start a low-cost
pilot training program but instead they
attracted the attention of aerospace
giant Boeing which donated to flight
simulators to the local school district
in hopes of stoking an early passion for
flying the goal was could we pull our
families out of poverty by showing them
careers in aviation which sounds a
little strange except if you know the
industry crisis that's that's brewing in
aviation across this next 15 years we're
going to see literally half of the
airline pilots currently flying retire
so we have to replace half of them that
crisis also prompted John Johnson to
start the flight science degree program
at nearby Ridley Junior College we're
the only state school in California that
allows the use of federal financial aid
and allows the use of VA benefits to
help cover the cost of flight training
that means instead of costly private
flying lessons students can learn to fly
at school and there are jobs waiting for
them when they graduate this is the time
to get in on this this is the best time
in the history of the United States to
become a commercial airline pilot yes I
have to say I like this class a lot yes
22 year-old Lorenzo Rios will graduate
with the first class of pilots this
summer
I got lights we got camera we got action
Rios is the son of an army lieutenant
colonel using his dad's VA benefits to
pay for school was his only option so
without those VA benefits would you have
been able to do this no that would have
been a very tough tough situation for me
this right here I mean you really can't
beat this view it's just absolutely
gorgeous
while the horizon for Rios is filled
with a promising career in the cockpit
for the younger kids of Reedley the view
from the ground is just beginning to
come to focus how important is it to
expose children at a young age
especially with these flight simulators
I think it's absolutely crucial I didn't
know what I wanted to do coming out of
high school Roger and when I started
flying the simulators it changed my
whole life such an exciting program and
John Johnson told me that the regional
airlines they're offering up to $40,000
signing bonuses for new pilots I bow
down to you man getting it thank you
what a great idea back down yeah Thank
You Meg we'll be right back